[Aplausos]
el dolor y la conmoción se convirtieron
en rabia y determinaciones de sábado
cuando un centenar de manifestantes
desafió la fría lluvia y se tomó las
calles de menfis su objetivo honrar y
recordar a tyrey Nichols de 29 años y
padre de un niño además de exigir
cambios drásticos en el sistema policial
del país un sistema que estos
manifestantes dicen no hace nada para
prevenir el uso de la violencia
básicamente lo que hay que hacer es
mejorar la policía necesitamos algún
tipo de entrenamiento un entrenamiento
mental para los agentes Porque algunos
de ellos están básicamente locos y les
gusta matar
desde la muerte de tyrey Nichols gran
parte de la indignación se ha centrado
en el uso excesivo de la fuerza policial
durante incidentes que son menores según
los agentes Nichols fue arrestado por
conducir rápido una detención violenta
que era totalmente innecesaria según
manifestantes creo que la gente no
necesita ser detenida por delitos no
violentos y la violencia no Debería ser
la primera respuesta a cualquier tipo de
conexión con agentes de la ley o
cualquier otra persona con autoridad sí
creo que todo el sistema necesita
cambiar
la policía es un sistema de supremacía
blanca y creo que también es importante
mencionar que no fueron solo cinco
policías negros sino que un policía
blanco utiliza un teaser contra nicoles
y luego les dijo a los demás que le
dieran una paliza antes de alejarse y
luego de sus cinco policías lo
persiguieron y lo asesinaron y ese
sistema es el que causó la muerte de
Nicole a mitad de la marcha a los
manifestantes recibieron una buena
noticia la disolución de la unidad
escorpio el grupo de los cinco hombres
responsables de la brutal paliza un gran
cambio de tono Solo un día después de
que el jefe de policía dijera que a
pesar de la muerte de Nichols la fuerza
especial había hecho más bien que mal